clustering or cluster analysis is one of
the foundational and most important
tasks that you can do in unsupervised
machine learning
the general idea is to take an entire
collection of cases or observations
and put them together now the important
thing to remember is these are not
natural groupings
rather these are groups of convenience
they're not the platonic real universals
that cut nature on its joints
they're groups of cases that are similar
to each other but with a pragmatic goal
you group the cases to accomplish a
specific purpose
and the real merit of the grouping is
how well does it serve that purpose you
can think of this as a version of
functionalism
and the question is which cases can be
treated in the same way depending on a
specific purpose
clustering serves really important
purposes in a lot of different fields
to give you a few examples in marketing
the idea here
is that you make offers to people who
are in similar categories
you give them the same kind of ads you
recommend the same products to them
it's extremely common in marketing in
medicine
you would use clustering to identify
similar patients or cases or outbreaks
or even medications that can be used for
similar kinds of diseases and disorders
in ecology and zoology you can use it to
identify
species and ways of categorizing the
environments that they live in
although it's not formally used in law
the basic idea here
is you're trying to argue that one case
is similar to another
if you wanted to do a quantitative
analysis you could establish that for
this particular purpose
this case is in the same category as all
of these others
and they go together and they're
different from these ones
that's what cluster analysis is about
note that clusters are pragmatic
groupings
they really serve a particular purpose
for the analyst or the purpose using
them
what clusters do is they allow limited
interchangeability between the objects
within the cluster
you want to hear these songs together
you're going to give the same ads to
this group over here
these people get the same medical
treatment and the approach is in the
validity of clustering varies according
to the individual person's purpose
the data that's fed into the system and
the algorithm used
the algorithm defines what it means to
be similar and it also defines how to
measure distance and what it means to be
a cluster
there are many choices available they
fall into a few general categories
for instance there are methods that
measure the distance between points like
euclidean distance
there are others that measure distance
from a centroid others that look at the
density of the data in the space
and others that use distributional
models if you have graph data that is
network data there are other models too
let's start by taking a quick look at
distance algorithms
imagine you have a collection of points
here in two-dimensional space
and that's one cluster in orange and
you've got another cluster here in blue
what you're going to do is you're going
to measure the distance from every point
to every other point
think of it as measuring the direct
distance between each of them
and these are also known as connectivity
models
one of the neat things you get from
these is a hierarchical diagram
one of the interesting choices here is
whether you want to do a joining
or splitting approach those are actually
technically known as agglomerative or
divisive
you either start with all of the data in
one cluster and then take it apart
or you start with all observations
separately and then join them together
sequentially
one of the tricks here is that these
distance models really only find convex
clusters
that is if you're in a two-dimensional
or three-dimensional shape
the other major limitation is that while
the distance models are easy to describe
they're really slow for big data because
you have to compute a big number of
distances
the next most common methods are the
centroid based models
imagine that you have cluster of points
here and what we get with this diamond
is a point that defines the mean in
multi-dimensional space here
what it does then is it looks at the
distance from every point in a group to
that centroid
the center point here the centroid is
defined by a mean vector
so it's the mean for that group on every
variable that you have in the
dimensional space
the most common version of this is
what's called k-means and that's where
you simply define how many centroids you
want to have
and then it figures out how far each
point is from so many different
centroids
like the distance models the centroid
model finds convex clusters
but with an extra limitation they're
generally of similar size
the other major problem is you have to
choose the value for k
the number of clusters that you want to
have there are some interesting
adaptation sways around that but
generally
you just kind of pick a number and you
give that to the computer
and see how well it works next there are
density algorithms
and this is where you look in the
multi-dimensional space and it simply
computes the density of points in there
and it draws a border around them so for
instance
what you're doing here is you're
connecting dense regions in
k-dimensional space where k is the
number of variables or attributes that
you have
what's neat about this is these
approaches can model non-convex clusters
you see for instance how the orange one
bends in
it can also model clusters of different
sizes
the blue one's smaller the orange one's
bigger and so it overcomes some of the
limitations of other approaches
one interesting thing is it is possible
to sort of ignore outliers or unusual
cases because they're not in dense
regions
the major problem however is that it's
hard to describe exactly how the
algorithm arrived at these things
you don't have a parametric distribution
to say that this cluster is defined by
high scores on this variable
and low scores on that one because it
might be an unusual shape that wraps
around the fourth collection of
algorithms are distributions or
distributional models
imagine we have our points here and we
draw a sort of normal shape around them
in a bivariate model that's going to
look like an ellipse
here we draw an approximate ellipse
around these points so what we're doing
here is we're getting the clusters
and we're modeling them as statistical
distributions
now you have a lot of choices but by far
the most common is a multivariate normal
distribution
and we're showing that with the variate
loose ellipses here
there's one major problem to the
distributional approach is that
it is prone to overfit that is if you
give the computer free reign
it'll just add more and more dimensions
until you end up with models that really
only apply to the exact data that you
currently have
now you can overcome that by telling it
how many dimensions to work with
similar to the k-means and tell it how
many clusters one advantage though is
it's good at capturing the correlations
or interrelations between the attributes
in your data
which none of the other approaches do
specifically
on the other hand it also is limited to
convex clusters because that's the shape
of our distributions
in summary there are multiple
definitions of clusters
there's definitions of what it means to
be a cluster how do they define distance
and how to define shape while there are
several categories of algorithms
each of them has different strengths and
limitations
for instance some only do convex shapes
some do equal size clusters
some are difficult for large data sets
some are hard to describe parametrically
so when it comes down to actually
conducting your cluster analysis
you need to be mindful of these auctions
and try to choose an algorithm that both
fits your data and fits the purposes or
pragmatic applications of your analysis